[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show is Connor Beaton he is
the founder of mentalks which is
um a group for men to help with their
progress and development as men he's
also a speaker he's an entrepreneur and
he's a writer so he has a new book
coming out called men's work and that's
what we talked about today was what's in
men's work and we kind of started with
the beginning of the book where it's
about discovering the shadow which to be
honest if you're a girl listening right
now like it's valuable for you too but
isn't it fun to listen to also stuff to
learn about men I love it anyway so
discovering the Shadow and then kind of
coming around to the end which the end
of the book is about like the final boss
that you have to face is the victim and
how we don't want to look at that victim
but this was such a a tangible call to
action kind of an episode where we talk
about very real things everything from
stress to to sex to how to get an
erection porn purpose roles masculine
feminine and he has just some really
really great ways to cope with things
that so many of us deal and deal with in
the world but especially men so enjoy
the conversation please hit the
Subscribe button also let me know what
you want to hear more about
um I love going through the comments and
we pick a lot of guests based on what
you say so enjoy the episode and please
uh feel free to liberally send this to
every man you know did you see me doing
the F1 broadcast at all you betcha you
betcha I loved it I was like yeah get it
well I had only done that one when I'd
seen you or I was about to do one maybe
and then I did
a four this year and I think maybe seven
or eight next year maybe oh my gosh well
we were we were talking about uh heading
down to Vegas maybe next year because
the race is on my birthday on November
18th and and I and I turned 40 next year
and so I was like well maybe we you know
pile some people
since you know Vegas is Vegas I've never
been before but I sort of have like a
natural
opposition to Vegas I think as my
younger self probably would have never
made it out of there alive you know like
I would have I would have had some like
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas moment
yeah and just and just you know Hunter S
Thompson out into the universe yeah yeah
I mean there's an opportunity to do just
about anything in Vegas you can go get a
massage you can work out in their you
know 50 000 square foot gyms or you can
party all night you know it's like it's
like dealer's Choice depends on what
cards you have to pull from the from
from the deck that's fair that'd be fun
but I think Vegas is supposed to be like
astronomically expensive did you see
there was one promotion for I don't
remember what hotel it was but they were
promoting a package
um that was for the race in a hotel and
whatever else and a few things and it
was um up for a bit of a million dollars
no come on
I mean it's like F1 is definitely the
bougia sport out there you know it's
like you're in Monaco you're watching
you know the race happen from a yacht
it's yeah you're right it might be
Enthusiast I I think it is I think I I I
definitely think it is I think it's like
the you know maybe besides some form of
like Polo or something like that you
know true well I'm excited to talk to
you I've been super deep diving on uh a
lot of a lot of your podcasts and
episodes on YouTube and and especially
these days I've been really interested
in the male perspective on things like
I've talked to a lot of men and women
but like I've just been much more
motivated and curious about how what
it's like to be a man right now and like
what the challenges are and then I have
about 50 000 other questions after that
great well I'm I'm up for it so I
appreciate you diving in and and the
interest in the in the perspective and
yeah so what's it what are what are the
biggest challenges do you think these
days for men that are maybe different
than they have been you know I think it
depends on a little bit of like where
you live your demographic I think
there's a number of things that that
play into it but I definitely think that
there's a bit of a consensus within the
male culture that
what it means to be a man is far less
clear than ever before and I think the
the necessity of being a man and
masculinity is far less maybe sort of
necessary than ever before you know I
think men are constantly hearing this
sort of notion of like well men aren't
needed I don't need a man and and uh you
know masculinity is dangerous and it's
toxic and so I think you know one of the
big challenges that I think a lot of men
face internally and within our culture
and within our society is just where do
I belong where am I needed where am I
wanted because there's a lot of stories
out there and a lot of narratives out
there and a lot of content that's been
put out on the internet that tells men
that they're not needed and they're not
wanted and that masculinity is dangerous
and that men net you know as a net are
sort of
um bad and so I think a lot of young men
are growing up
in this culture that's telling them that
masculinity is dangerous and that being
a man is is sort of harmful and you can
see this in in some of the literature
that's out there right like the American
Psychological Association the APA back
in 2019 uh or 2018 put out guidelines
for therapists and psychologists to work
with men and boys and in the guidelines
they they actually state that quote
unquote traditional masculinity is
harmful both the men and women [__] and
so you have not only culture uh and
Society sort of saying hey you know men
are struggling men are you know in
Decline you and you can kind of see this
across the board right less men are
going to college less men are entering
into the workforce
um we are at the highest rate right now
in terms of men between the ages of 18
and 30.
um having uh sexual relationships so
less men than ever before are entering
into sexual relationships between 18 and
30 it's actually up three times from
what it was in 2010. so you have this
huge population of men that are kind of
checking out from culture and from
society and being told that being a man
by some people right not by everybody I
just want to make that clear but by some
people are telling them you know if
you're a man
uh or if you are masculine and you value
masculine tenants and masculine
characteristic characteristics and
traits
then you're dangerous and you're harmful
and you're not needed in society
um so I think that's one of the big
challenges and then I think that you
know there's many other things that we
could talk about but one of the things
that I focused in on and I focus in on
my work and my writing
is the the impact of of
um not having a father around and so
this sort of plague of absent fathers
and we can see again in the literature
that not having a father in the
household specifically can be quite
dangerous so you know it's something
like
of uh all homeless and runaway children
come from fatherless homes 63 percent of
Youth suicides are from fatherless homes
uh 85 percent of all children who show
behavioral disorders come from
fatherless homes so this is you know
this is sort of endemic within our
culture and our society and we know that
not having a father around a male figure
around is damaging to a child's
development especially young boys where
a father's role is to help regulate that
young boy's aggression and aggressive
tendencies and so and also to help
children just take risks right to sort
of like promote this risk-taking so I
think those are some of the challenges
that men are facing I think dating is
maybe not favorable for anybody these
days I think it's a bit of a nightmare
just from talking to people doesn't
matter what your gender is it doesn't
matter where you live it doesn't matter
how you vote I think you know I think
dating apps have largely caused a little
bit of challenge within the dating world
and so I don't think that's a male
specific thing but I do hear a lot of
men
um complaining about the dating field
but I think that I hear a lot of women
complaining well do you think that that
falls in line with you just said like
there's a narrative out there that
women don't need men is there a
narrative on the other side of it where
men don't need women
or is it more of a turning away from
this sort of
new expectation levels or needs or wants
that just maybe just don't fit or don't
know how to fit right yet you know I
think our culture has gone through a
massive uh shift over the last however
many decades and everybody's trying to
figure out what their roles are and what
that looks like and so I I do think that
some there are some men that are like I
don't need a woman in my life and of
course we're talking to heterosexual
context but I do think that there are
some men that say that but I think
predominantly at least from my viewpoint
there's a lot of communication to women
that you shouldn't need a man right in
order to be a good woman or strong woman
or a good whatever it is right feminist
Etc you shouldn't need a man in your
life and so I I do think that that gets
uh that permeates into the conversation
that permeates into dating it permeates
into how people approach being around
and I do think that some men carry this
like I don't need a woman in my life but
I think generally most men do want
partnership you know they do want a
relationship of some form or another and
and I think women do as well I just
think that it's different narratives
that are being permeated I think
generally what you'll hear a man talk
about is
um you know my purpose comes first right
my mission in life comes first that
doesn't mean I don't want a woman to
come along the journey with me right
that doesn't mean that at all it just
means that there's a priority within me
to to want to have my purpose and my
function and my mission Primary in my
life and and I think you know largely we
maybe underestimate
how much men want to be needed within
culture and Society you know it's a very
base and core foundational drive that
many of us as men carry within us is
like I want to be needed in my
relationship in my family in my culture
I want to have a very clear function
that gives me a sense of meaning and
purpose within my life and so when we
start to extract that out of the
equation and you know like I remember
reading because people send me articles
all the time because I talk about this
stuff right and there's you'd be
surprised how many articles are out
there uh if you just went in Google
search like is the world better without
men there's a ton of them asking these
questions of like you know would the
world be better without men and it's
like well why is that even a freaking
question it's the last generation if
that's the case so one interesting
perspective right so that's so negative
so a man wants to be needed he needs to
be needed maybe then actually the word
is need man needs to be needed
um which sort of equates to a role so
can what the chicken or the egg what do
you think is there is there a hierarchy
of of order of which it falls between
purpose
and being needed do you have to find
your purpose before you can be receive a
relationship or do you find your purpose
by being needed in a relationship that
then sort of opens you up to something
greater it's a good question I don't
know if there's necessarily A hierarchy
or like an order there I think generally
speaking
uh I don't know how much flocking I get
for this but like your relationship
cannot be your purpose or your function
in life you can't be a mission and it
can be a part of where we feel satiated
and where we get you know human
connection and nourishment from Love and
deep conversations and a partner to
explore with and many of those things
but uh but and we can feel needed within
that relationship but I our our purpose
needs to come outside of a relationship
so what I usually say is like men
respond to calling men respond to being
called to serve something support
something build something create
something during structure and order to
something and that calling is where we
begin to find a space or a sense of
needing right so if we see that there's
a problem that's existing within culture
or Society we can feel a calling to want
to go and do something about that or if
we can see that something's broken or
needs support or needs fixing we can
feel called to go and have that be a
part of our mission in life so I think
that those are two sort of separate
things that men are often grappling with
is that they they want to find a sense
of of purpose and meaning and a mission
in life and they want somebody to come
along
with them or to share that Journey with
them uh as they as they go through life
I think what happens in a lot of modern
relationships which we call codependency
is that men don't have meaning or
function or purpose something meaningful
outside of a relationship that they find
joy in and they feel like they have a
function in that lights them up that
causes them to develop a sense of
Mastery and skill in the world and so
they put a tremendous amount of pressure
onto the relationship and the
relationship becomes their sole sense of
function and meaning and purpose and so
where they derive joy and happiness from
uh ends up coming from the relationship
and it can impress a lot of of pressure
and expectation onto that relationship
right sort of causing the other person
to feel like oh you don't have a lot
going on outside of me and that can be a
lot for the relationship to carry and I
think it's one of the challenges that
modern day relationships face is that
we've sort of Disney fied relationships
and we've we've been sold this
expectation of that you know you should
find that one person and it should be
perfect and it should be amazing and
they should fill all your buckets in the
world and so you have a lot of people
that are looking for a relationship
and their expectations is that their
partner should be their lover and their
Confidant and their emotional processing
center and their therapist and their
coach and their financial advisor and
like every single role Under the Sun
they want that from a partner and so
we've we've put a lot of expectations
into the into the realm of relationships
and so I know I kind of took that in a
little bit of a different direction but
yeah I think generally speaking men uh
find a sense of mission find a sense of
purpose by looking out in the world and
starting to say what do I feel called to
contribute to what do I feel called to
bring my energy and my skills and my
values and my perspective and my
intelligence too and and what can I
really contribute to there's there's
immense value in that do you think that
it's I'm just going to put it on equal
playing field do you think that it a man
and a woman both need to have an idea
idea have a have a goal have a direction
of who they want to become do you think
they always need to be sort of striving
towards something or is it okay to be
settled like this is it
um
I think that there is value and validity
in having a period of your life where
you strive very ferociously towards the
possibility of who you could become to
create and carve out a vision of this is
what I think I'm capable of physically
mentally emotionally financially
relationally you know here's what I
think I could build in the world here's
what I think I could uh contribute to
within my society and my community
here's what I think I'm capable of
within my own mind and body within my
own spiritual practices and then to
really steer yourself towards that aim
and it doesn't mean that you're going to
accomplish it you know wholeheartedly
doesn't mean you're gonna like you know
go down the list and and knock all that
off but without that aim without that
possibility of seeing what you're you're
capable of you're sort of wandering
around you know in the dark and you know
one of the things that I talk about a
lot is this this concept of shot Auto
work which was you know created by Carl
Jung back in the 20th century and
without us really starting to create a
vision of who we think we could become
the version of us that we could step
into
nothing changes and we stay in this this
space of mediocrity which is very uh
very rampant within our culture right
and we stay in this space of comfort and
over prioritizing safety and comfort
which again is very rapid within our
culture and so I think a lot of people
both men and women feel wildly
domesticated within our culture right
now very domesticated there's very
little wildness within our day-to-day
lives and so when you create this
version of who you could become it
requires a little bit of wildness you
have to get out of your Norm you have to
venture out into the the territory of
the unknown and start to discern like
what am I actually capable of you know
and can I push myself into this unknown
territory of of what I could do
physically or emotionally or
relationally or sexually or financially
and and when you start to ask that
question that's where change really
starts to happen that's where you start
to meet your Edge and when I say your
Edge I mean again the the limits of your
current capacities and you start to
expand the limitations that you
currently have and that's where
transformation starts to take place
so can you articulate what that what
that experience is like because I think
these are really important
um things to be heard because well it's
not always pretty and people usually
stop when things get hard so can you
just sort of give a quick little glimpse
into what it looks like to go into these
spaces these edges that are unfamiliar
but sort of on the precipit of the next
level for you or something that you want
yeah so as an example if you start to
create a vision of what you want
relationally or physically I'll just use
sort of two alternating examples you
might say I want to see what my body is
capable of okay and so you can be
realistic with where you're at you can
say here's where I'm at right now I'm
average weight average height I haven't
really worked out that much and I want
to see what I'm capable of physically so
I want to see how much muscle mass can I
put on how much can I bench press and
squat you know can I run an ultra
marathon and so you start to create a a
vision of what it is that you think you
might be capable of and then work your
way back from there right and again what
you might be capable of has to also
align with with something that you care
about right I I personally have zero
interest in doing an ultra marathon some
people do but I want to see what I'm
capable of physically in terms of like
strength you know what can I accomplish
there and then flexibility I want to see
what I can accomplish there and so we
have to create the vision of what that
looks like and create some metrics that
go alongside with it and so those
metrics might be
you know within the next year I want to
gain a certain amount of muscle mass I
want to reduce my uh my body body mass
index right I want to reduce that I want
to keep track of my glucose levels and
start to get a sense of what causes my
body to spike in glucose and so you can
start to iron out all the different
pieces that are going to contribute to
you seeing what it is that you're
capable of within that one field another
example is within your relationship
right I think a lot of people
um how do I want to say this I think
that many people have a entertainment
version or view of what their sex life
could look like
and we're going to talk about porn trust
me and uh and so I think it it sort of
diminishes our capacity to really
understand what we could be capable of
sexually with in the bedroom with our
partner or or whatever that your
relationship status looks like and so
you have to be able to be willing to say
like what might I be capable of not from
an ego standpoint but what might I be
sexually capable of if I remove some of
the constraints if I was willing to face
my fears or my preconceived notions of
what it means to be a sexual being or
what my religious upbringing told me
that I still you know I no longer follow
that that Doctrine but I'm still sort of
following it in within my relationship
right so if I threw away those confines
what might I be capable of and what
steps what action would I have to take
what Edge would I have to push what
fears would I have to face and so you
can start to look at that from a place
of maybe you go and take a tantra class
right or a BDSM class or Shibari or
whatever it is where you start to bring
breath work into sexual encounters and
interactions and in doing so every
single action that you take is going to
push an edge right because all of those
things that I just listed off there very
briefly from for most people if they
just chose one of those things to do
like sitting down with her partner and
uh using breath as a means to create
intimacy and to create presence within
the sexual interaction that would push
an edge for them you know immediately
that would probably be uncomfortable
you're like oh what am I doing this is
weird right and so
so I think you're uncomfortable so
getting uncomfortable
yes getting uncomfortable being able to
see who you become in the face of
discomfort most of us don't like who we
are when we're faced with discomfort and
that's the shadow right we don't like
who we are because we become yes we
become insecure and avoidant and we
project our [__] on the other person we
blame them and we become Petty and we
attack and you know all that kind of
stuff so we don't like two things we
don't like who we become oftentimes when
we're facing discomfort and for us as
men I'll just speak for the male
perspective especially I think it
applies to women as well
we generally don't want to see who we
become when we feel powerless
and so a huge part of a man's work is to
see who he becomes when he feels
powerless right within the context of a
relationship right so just I'll give you
an example because it's sort of maybe
vague say you're in a relationship with
somebody and you keep having these
conflicts and you're trying to solve
this problem with your partner you can't
figure it out and you're like what the
hell is going on and why can't I fix
this and why does she keep getting mad
at me about this there's a sense of
powerlessness that is showing up within
your relationship and within you right I
feel helpless to change this I can't
solve this problem for her I can't fix
this and when does this also include
like I don't want to does that become
part of the sure narrative as well okay
yeah yeah I don't want to that's usually
that's usually on the other side right
it's usually when we feel powerless that
we begin to use these coping mechanisms
right it's like okay I can't help this I
feel helpless I feel powerless and so
I'm going to check out I'm not going to
deal with it I'm not going to talk to
her anymore I'm not going to engage I
don't care right I don't give a crap and
so we have to be willing to see our own
reactivity our own anger our own
mechanisms of avoiding when we feel
powerless and enter into that space
because if we're not willing to do that
then we're forcing other people to deal
essentially with who we become in the
moments of our powerlessness and that's
generally A Pretty Petty uh pretty
accusatory childish person right that's
that's what most of us resolve to right
we sort of uh degrade into children when
we feel helpless or powerless
and of course that that uh that kind of
um emotion comes out the you know no
it's you I want to go a little deeper
into how to discover Your Shadow because
you gave a great example but for so many
um even myself like I think this is
applicable for everyone to be honest is
what are some tricks or some indicators
to give you insight into what your
Shadow is or where you can start to kind
of go deeper
um into it
yeah so just really quickly to Define
what the shadow is
essentially the shadow is the part of
you that you don't want other people to
know about right it's the sort of
conglomeration of your insecurities your
fears uh your perceived inferiorities
and generally speaking those
those parts of you because they are
parts of you were created when you felt
betrayed as a kid or you felt abandoned
or you felt abused or you felt neglected
or you were bullied at school you know
for the way your body looked or uh for
being stupid or whatever the case may be
and so we all have these parts to us
that we don't want other people to know
about and then we have parts to us which
I'm going to avoid talking a little bit
about right now that we don't want to
see
right so there's parts of us that we
don't know about that we're like oh I
don't even want to see that [__] right
so where do we begin well the easiest
place the easiest place and and maybe
I'll just say one more thing about it
um before I just sort of give you the
the access point
the reason why the shadow is so
important is because this is the
psychological material that gets in the
way of your goals and your aims and your
trajectory and what you want to build
and what you want to create and the type
of relationships that you want to have
the shadow is the part of you that
sabotages that that gets in the way it's
like no you don't deserve that now
you're not worthy Or Nah you should stay
up until three o'clock in the morning
and get shit-faced and you know show up
to that that big presentation with that
important meeting with that client
hungover as hell right so the shadow is
that part of you and there's a a great
American therapist named Francis Weller
who says your pain has its own
intelligence your pain has its own
intelligence right so our work and this
I tell this to men all the time our work
is to start to face our pain right I the
first line of my book is a man's work
begins in pain so we have to begin to
start to understand what is that what is
the intelligence of our pain trying to
say or is it trying to communicate and
where is it already expressing itself in
our life you know because if we can
start to pay attention to that then we
can get a sense of what's happening
within us right so okay with all that
said when we do this we begin to reclaim
these parts of us right in mythology you
see people enter into the cave face the
dragon reclaim the gold right so when
you do Shadow work you enter in the cave
you face the dragon your insecurities
your inner critic right that judgmental
voice is just constantly [__] talking
you
um and you reclaim the gold so that part
of you gets to have a place within your
inner Kingdom where you're not at odds
with it you're not fighting it you
actually have built some kind of a
relationship with it so where we see it
is within what what Jung called our
reactivity so anytime that you become
reactive or AKA defensive critical of
somebody else judgmental of somebody
else shutting down right avoiding a
conversation that reactivity is a big
neon sign yeah pointing towards your
Shadow saying hey I'm acting from my
pain from my hurt from this part of me
that I my insecurities right you might
have probably felt your Shadow if you've
ever been in a relationship where all of
a sudden you found yourself like you
know needy is all hell stage five
Klinger texting the other person
constantly you know it's like okay I
know I just texted them six times in a
row and I know I probably shouldn't do
this again but I'm going to text them
anyway even though they haven't
responded right uh so that's the shadow
right it's like I feel unworthy I feel
needy
um and I I don't feel worthy of this
person's love and care and attention so
that reactivity is what we need to start
to pay attention to that's the access
point okay
so what I usually say is
don't react regulate and respond don't
react regulate and respond and all that
means is that
there's a I'll just bring in a great
author Victor Frankel wrote man search
for meaning he said between stimulus and
response there's a pause when we are
acting from our reactivity it's largely
unconscious we are not pausing right
we're not noticing what we're feeling or
experiencing and for the most part we're
not even
um consciously
deciding whether what we're saying to
that other person is uh congruent or in
Integrity for us right we're just
reacting screw you how could you you
know why don't you you always you never
and we are communicating from this very
unconscious place it's why when you hear
people say like oh I just lost it you
know in that argument I just lost it
yeah what did you lose what did you lose
in that moment right it's like no you
lost your Consciousness right and you
lost your conscious capacity to respond
to that other person in a healthy
grounded way how do we catch it
okay
yes so so very I'm going to give you
four steps okay because people love
their their bullet points and their
steps hell yeah we do it's just it's
very helpful right it's very very
helpful so the the very first step that
we need to become uh aware of is we need
to get familiar with the signs familiar
with the signs that we are being
reactive so we need to get familiar with
the physical signs what does that
reactivity feel like in the body you
know when you're getting angry this is
some work here for everyone but
especially for men I feel like to like
actually feel things viscerally to feel
where it hits in the body and what's
happening with your heart rate what's
happening with your 10 how tense are you
with your stomach feel like what does
your chest feel like why do you feel
like that's so important having maybe
been on the other side I think it is the
ultimate lie detector I think that your
mind can lie to you but your body
doesn't very true what's it like to be
around a man who is disconnected from
what his body is experiencing
like if he's like I'm not angry and
you're feeling like his body's just
emanating anger what's that like
it's a wall
it feels like a wall it feels like
there's no way to get through that
because there's dissonance around the
truth and always trying to get around it
somehow some way not listening to not
listening to their body not feeling
their body and matching that up with
something vulnerable like it lacks
vulnerability because usually behind
that body is the feeling is a truth
that's usually people I feel like aren't
actually like mad at you they're
triggered into an emotion because of
something that happened to them in their
past so it's like you're part of it but
it's not really about you
yeah so it's harder to trust them yeah
right it's harder to trust them it's
hard to really trust a person who is
saying one thing rationally or
intellectually but their body is
emitting a very different truth right
and so so we have to get clear on what
the signs are especially physically it's
just like okay when I feel anger what
does that feel like you know for me the
analogy I always give is I'll start to
feel a little bit of fire in my belly
and then at some point it's almost like
the for people I've seen Iron Man who's
got that like energy piece in his chest
that sort of like lights up it's like
there's a point where I just feel that
come online I feel a huge intensity in
my chest and then it starts to you know
Bubble Up and so generally speaking for
most men when that energy of their anger
gets into their head is when it's it's
lost right so we have to be able to pay
attention to the energy in the body
first what we're experiencing what we're
feeling so we have to get clear on the
signs physically but we also have to get
clear on the signs uh verbally what does
it sound like when you're reactive you
know do you get louder do you hear
yourself saying certain things do you
hear yourself complaining about this you
know the same thing over and over again
do you hear yourself uh using what we
call universals right you always you
never right which are these sort of
absolute statements about how the other
person is acting do you catch yourself
being very critical of the person so get
clear on what the signs are
when you are reactive and if you really
aren't too sure you know obviously you
start physically but inquire with people
that you trust you know it's like when I
get reactive when I'm angry when I'm
disconnected I'm shutting down what does
it look like what does it sound like to
you and what does it feel like to you
and your body and that'll give you some
Clues as to what it looks like and what
it sounds like and then what it feels
like to to be around you so that's
number one number two is to just name it
out loud right just say I'm being
reactive right or I'm being angry or I'm
being aggressive or I'm being critical
right whatever it is that you're
actually being in that moment from
reactivity because ownership the first
one is awareness right getting very
clear on what you're feeling and then
the second one is ownership right so
naming it out loud and then third say
what you're actually feeling so
for most of us in almost every single
moment what we're actually experiencing
is not the anger it's something
underneath right we were embarrassed we
were ashamed we were sad we felt lonely
right we've we felt disappointed
whatever it is right and so what I say
in the book is that it's easier for a
man to say [__] you than it is to say
I'm hurt
it just is so much easier right and I
felt that in my own life it's so much
easier for me to say [__] you to the
world or Society or my partner or my
friends or my family than it is to say
[__] that hurt you know that really hurt
what you did what you said you know
forgetting to call me or for whatever it
is that hurt me and so we have to
practice being strong enough to say that
hurt me I didn't like that you know so
the third step say what you're actually
feeling and then lastly
shift the attention from your mind into
your body shift your cognition to
sensation physically so Einstein had a
great quote he said the the rational
mind is a faithful servant and the
intuitive mind is a sacred gift but
we've created a culture that honors the
servant the rational mind and has
forgotten about the gift
and we as men have been brought up in
this culture
um right or wrong that over indexes the
rational mind that tells us that the
rational mind is going to solve every
single problem in our life and so that's
the tool that we deploy whenever
something's going wrong but the very
simple truth is that your rational mind
cannot solve emotional problems it
cannot solve emotional equations so when
you're dealing with an emotional
challenge in your relationship your
rational mind's very limited to figure
it out very very limited so if you can't
speak the language of emotion and you
can't feel the energy of that in your
body you're stunted in Your Capacity to
move you or the relationship through
that problem that's happening whether
it's something that's happening within
your sex life or your finances in the
relationship or whatever the
disagreement is so we have to be willing
to move into the realm of sensation can
I be with the heat of the anger can I be
with the weight of the sadness can I
move my mind literally out of my
rational thoughts how do I fix this how
do I solve this how do I figure out what
she needs into what am I experiencing
right now in this moment talk about the
role of stress with men and you know I
think that you know while there's roles
being sort of questioned or challenged
um you know especially when we think
about the earning power of women
continues to go up right now
um that I think there's a certain age
right now at a very young age is
outperforming men financially they're
making more money than men these days
they're doing better in school there's a
lot of things so but yet a man feels
like a man like this is what I
understand wants to be needed needs a
role as a provider keeps a woman safe
all kinds of things like that so what
role like there's a lot of things to
stress a man out so talk about the role
of stress and how that plays into
um
their ability to have those rational
conversations or body guided
conversations to sex life to connection
and being able to let those walls down
like what role does stress play in the
body it's that's a big awesome question
because it's a it plays a massive role
in a lot of men's lives in a lot of Our
Lives I think in general I wanted to say
one thing you know there was research
that was done I think just before the
pandemic that showed that 42 percent of
American households and 42 percent of
American households uh the female
Partners out earning the male partner
yeah and so we've entered into a space
where in almost half of American
households the woman is the primary
breadwinner
and so roles have shifted wow um you
know Financial uh the way that things
look within the household has shifted
but I think our capacity to have the
conversations that's a giant glass of
water by the way that's that is awesome
it's a perspective thing it's not even
it's not even a mason jar it's just just
a giant glass of water I love that
um that should hopefully encourage
people to go watch the videos
amazing right
um so you know I think we in our culture
we need to be able to have these
conversations yeah but so I just that's
just wanted to put that out there in
terms of the the role that stress plays
I think it plays a role in many
different things I'm gonna just approach
this by breaking down what actually
happens within our body because I think
I didn't actually know this I don't
think most people actually know this you
know you have two branches to your
autonomic nervous system you have your
uh sympathetic and your parasympathetic
right your sympathetic is like the gas
pedal so that's what happens when you're
getting stuff done when you're working
when you're working out it's tied to
your fight flight or freeze response so
when conflict happens or you feel more
stressed out you're in this state and
your body has a very specific response
when you're in that sympathetic response
state right so your uh your breath per
minute goes up so you're actually
breathing faster your heart rate goes up
right so your body's working a little
bit harder your body's releasing more
cortisol more adrenaline depending on
how stressed that you actually are and
then on the other side of the spectrum
is your parasympathetic which is like
the the brake pedal right so that's
responsible for rest digest being calm
feeling peaceful Etc
interesting fact that most people don't
know is that in order for a man to be
aroused
in order for a man to get an erection he
has to be in a parasympathetic dominant
state within his nervous system so he
actually has to be in a more restful
more calm digestive state in order to
get aroused so a lot of the non-medical
erectile dysfunction problems that
happen a lot of the non-medical
premature ejaculation challenges that
men face is not because there's
something physically going wrong besides
the fact that they can't get out of that
stress State they literally cannot move
their body out of this place of the
breath is going really fast their heart
rate is elevated their body's releasing
cortisol stress hormones adrenaline Etc
and then it gets worse too the more time
you spend in sympathetic the harder it
is to get into parasympathetic right
that's right that's right yeah so your
body sort of acclimatizes to this like
go go go you know maxed out always on
State and it becomes hard for a man to
feel regulated to feel grounded right
there's a lot of terms that get thrown
around out there but it becomes hard for
a man's body and mind to move out of
this stress State and into a relaxed
state so what do we do right we turn to
things like alcohol which is a
suppressant we turn to things like weed
which is supposed to help us calm down
well there's a lot of research now
coming out that if you're a chronic user
which is more than twice a week of
smoking weed that over uh along over a
period of time that can actually
increase your level of Stress and
Anxiety it can actually deregulate your
body and your nervous system even more
so Andrew huberman has some great
research on that wow and and so we turn
to porn right porn is probably the
number one way that men try to regulate
their nervous system to feel relaxed to
feel calm because after you watch porn
after you ejaculate your body a man's
body will actually release things like
dopamine so you feel good oxytocin the
bonding chemical and then something
called prolactin
which in women is response responsible
for something very different but for men
it's actually a calming down agent so
it's a neurochemical that gets released
and says to a male body you should calm
down you should relax a little bit so
it's why a lot of men after getting off
they feel a little bit sleepy they feel
tired their body moves into this very
like restful state right so so this
level of stress occupying this territory
um causes us to largely feel
more insecure
struggle to make more concrete decisions
create Direction vision for our life
have challenging conversations right go
through conflict in a healthy way which
is incredibly important for any
relationship right the number one uh
thing that any relationship needs to to
do is to get through conflict in a
healthy positive way to come out the
other side okay so what we need as human
beings and so all of these things become
more challenging right focusing on your
task it can you know increase ADHD so
stress is a huge challenge for a lot of
people and so we and and the problem is
that we live in a society that
prioritizes medication versus meditation
well I mean people use people use
marijuana for medication to like go to
sleep right
yeah and you know I think again
the literature on that is uh not great
you know like
because the THC content we probably
don't need to go down this path too too
much but because the THC content has
been like wildly dialed up uh for a lot
of people over time what will start to
happen
is that it actually replaces you know it
binds with a CB1 receptor in your brain
which is the the primary receptor to
your nervous system
and so it actually starts to replace
your body's natural process of of
regulating and so you start to create
this little bit of a dependency on it to
feel like you're calm and grounded and
de-stressed and that can feel good for a
while but for the majority of people
what will start to happen is if they're
using more than twice a week for a
prolonged period of time is that that
will wear off and they'll actually start
to feel more anxious
especially if you don't use it right if
you don't use it you lose it that's good
that's good
what are the good releases what can a
man do for Relief instead of turning to
something like porn instead of turning
to alcohol instead of turning to
cheating instead of turning to react
overreacting to things like instead of
doing those things or avoiding leaving
the home whatever that that that that
may be what are healthy
forms of relief or release
so there are some very basic things
right there's some very basic things I
think you know if you listen to podcast
if you're somebody that listens to
podcast quite a bit you've probably
heard this big push on most health
people's podcasts to uh cold immersion
right to sort of like cold therapy to uh
saunas to breath work and there's a
reason for that your breath is the
primary
um
the the primary thing that can actually
impact the dial between your stressed
part of your nervous system and your
relaxed part of your nervous system
right so if you're really stressed out
you're very anxious because there's
almost no difference from a neurological
stance between Stress and Anxiety
they're they're almost the same
neurologically right in terms of the
chemicals that get released and how your
nervous system is operating Etc so your
breath is the pathway that can help you
move out of that stressed state so if
you use very specific breathing
exercises right one of them is called
the Box breath which has been very
popularized right so you inhale for a
count of four you pause for a count of
four you exhale for a count of four and
you pause for a count of four and you do
that box cycle for about five minutes
and when you do that you're regulating
your breath cycle to such a degree where
you're sending a signal to your heart to
slow down so as you regulate your breath
your body starts to naturally relax your
heart rate starts to naturally decrease
and then your brain starts to reduce the
amount of stress chemicals that it's
going to be emitting out into your
system that's a good one another breath
cycle that has been researched time and
time again to help with HRV and it's
specifically given to people with PTSD
and that people that are prone to panic
attacks is inhaling through the nose for
a count of four pausing for a count of
two and then exhaling out the mouth for
a count of six and pausing for two and
so you do that cycle
again for four five six minutes and what
actually happens is that when you exhale
longer on the exhale than you do on the
inhale that compression slows down the
heart rate naturally right so it
actually slows down the heart rate over
time and decreases stress within the
body and it sort of not forces but
naturally causes your body to move into
a more parasympathetic calm oriented
state it might feel challenging at first
a lot of people that that have high
levels of anxiety and high levels of
stress for the first 60 to 120 seconds
it's probably going to be like oh this
is super labored and it's challenging
it's hard but that's the point is that
you're interfering with your body with
your body's normal patterns right
because for most people the more
stressed they are the more anxious they
are the faster they're breathing right
the more unconscious unconscious they
are with their breath and the faster
that they're breathing so your breath is
the first part
the second part of how you can start to
de-stress
is prioritizing things that are
uncomfortable but you're choosing that
discomfort right so this is why Cold
immersion is a is a very big uh there's
a big push for it because what's
happening when you're doing that is
you're putting your body into a natural
stress State and you are calming
yourself under that duress so it's like
a training ground for you to actually
like put yourself into a naturally
stressed State even if you just want to
do a cold shower right if you're not
like I don't want to go jump into an
Arctic you know lake or river sure just
do a warm shower and at the end of the
cold shower turn it at the end of the
hot shower turn it to cold as cold as
you can take it for about 60 seconds
regulate your breath focus in on your
breath right because your breath's going
to want to go like
you go
you know like that's kind of what you do
when you get that cold because you just
you you realize you're getting out of
control yeah so that and there's a ton
of benefits to this right and this is
um you know there was a study that
showed that just by taking a 60-second
cold shower every single day the people
in the study to reduce the amount of six
days sick days that they were taking by
30 to 40 percent within it within a
single year right so it's actually
helping your body regulate it's
decreasing inflammation it's uh
balancing out the pH levels within your
body which is a very important thing
because the more acidic your body is the
more inflamed it is and then the more
volatile you are right so that's another
simple one and then I think the last one
which is sort of unsexy and this is the
one that I always advocate for
because it's it's like it's honestly
what I had to do uh for a number of
years was you got to sit in the fire you
have to sit in the fire of the intensity
of what you're feeling in your body and
so I would just do something that I
started calling the fire meditation
which is that the when I felt the most
angry the most aggravated the most sad
the most depressed the most lonely is
when I would just go sit down and set a
timer for 10 minutes and close my eyes
and breathe and feel into the intensity
of what I was experiencing in my body
and that's
it's so important because the majority
of the time when we have conflict in our
relationship or with our boss or with
some random person at the coffee shop
it's not what they're saying that's the
problem it's what we feel in our bodies
that's the issue we want to get away
from the intensity of what we're
experiencing within the vessel of our
body
right so if you can begin to increase
your tolerance and understanding that
what you're experiencing is not a threat
it's not a danger it's not a problem
you're actually practicing what the
stoics talked about right that's what
stoicism was it was to be able to expand
your tolerance for what you were
experiencing internally without
demonizing what you're experiencing it's
not that you completely got rid of your
emotions or you became or there's this
notion in our modern culture that
stoicism is about being emotionless
that's not it it's that you're aware of
what you're experiencing internally but
it's not a problem and so for some of us
how we do that is by sitting and
breathing and feeling this the intensity
of those Sensations it's like
one of the most challenging things in
dealing with men that have anger
challenges right where their their anger
is very volatile and it overruns them is
that they actually have to practice
building tolerance for their internal
state
and this is what Buddhism and meditation
and a lot of these other sort of
spiritual Traditions are teaching is
that you have to sit with your internal
experience and so that's one of the
biggest practices that anyone can do at
any time right you get into conflict
with your partner or boss or whatever
and it doesn't feel good you know you
sort of feel disregulated you're not
communicating properly remove yourself
go sit for 10 minutes close your eyes
breathe and feel the intensity of the
body and notice how
much you are flailing to get away from
that experience right
right and your strength will increase to
be able to have more tolerance for it
full stop responsive training it's kind
of like it's like the cold that's right
yeah and so you know that's why like in
our within my company man talks or our
slogans it's not therapy it's training
you know I think a lot of what men are
like therapy isn't sexy to us as guys
you know I had a big aversion to it for
a long time and like here I am doing the
work right married to a freaking one of
the best therapists in the world right
and so it's it's kind of a kind of
ironic but I think in many ways what we
as men are looking for like whenever a
man comes to me and he's like I don't
feel confident I don't feel confident in
who I am and what I want what he's
actually lacking is is some sort of
competence within himself the ability to
feel like I am competent in what I do I
can confidently sit with my emotions or
communicate with my partner or ask for
my needs or set a boundary or say no
it's actually a skill set problem for
the most part and so if we can approach
this as hey you know what maybe nobody
taught you how to in a very skilled way
be with your anger maybe nobody taught
you in a very skilled way how to
communicate your needs or a set of
boundary and that's okay and that's not
a problem because that's a skill right
just like discipline disciplines a skill
so you know in terms of what we were
talking about before to just tie this in
when you have a vision of who it is that
you want to become part of that is what
skills do you want to acquire what do
you need yeah what do you need along the
way yeah I want to talk about something
that you talk about a lot
um I want to hear about non-conformity
and you know I think that maybe
I think this is a really great
conversation to have because I feel like
this could be the entry point for men to
start to you know have more confidence
be able to be more regulated to be more
autonomous to be more calm like there's
just I think this is a a really cool
cool
um
topic to dive into and just explaining
what non-conformity is and how does that
how does that look for for a man you
know I think that we live in this kind
of cult of specialness within our modern
culture that tells us that we should
conform to what it means to fit into
society and to be special and everyone
wants to be you know sort of very very
special and and but generally generally
what that looks like is conforming to
the modern narrative and I think for a
lot of men they've gotten caught in a
trap Not all men right they just want to
make that very clear but certainly for
myself in my younger days I fell into
the Trap of trying to be special by
conforming to what I thought other
people wanted what I thought culture
wanted what I thought Society wanted and
especially what I thought women wanted
like I was lost as a young man turning
myself into a pretzel trying to figure
out who women and wanted me to be and so
I was a very Adept very good chameleon
but I didn't really have a strong sense
of who the hell I was and what I wanted
and what my actual identity was because
I had been so
um brought into this idea that in order
to make a woman happy in order to have a
woman like me and in order to get a
woman's attention and validation I had
to become who she wanted me to be
and so there were all these opposing
stories and narratives that told me this
is how I should operate as a man in
order to make women happy socially from
a societal standpoint but more
specifically within relationship
and so there was this innate threat
of me
going against that grain of actually
being authentic to who I was and what I
wanted and to speak that in the context
of relationship
we as men have a very peculiar
relationship with fear you know we
operate from this notion that
suppression equals strength and that the
more I can suppress and hide my fear
hide what I'm afraid of hide my
insecurities the stronger I will be but
it's it actually has a very net negative
impact on our lives and so this notion
of Conformity non-conformity is that you
actually start to carve out a sense of
individuality right this is what Jung
called the process of individuation
process of wholeness the process of
honoring who you authentically are and
and so it means that you have to start
to identify how have you been trading
your own authenticity
for belonging how have you been trading
your own authenticity for validation for
like you know for Facebook likes or
Instagram or whatever it is or for
attention from the opposite sex or for a
sense of belonging in your work
environment and you have to sort of be
willing to go against that grain because
there's something within us as
specifically within the sort of
masculine nature that values
non-conformity and that that
non-conformity plays a very
specific and very important role within
our culture right if everyone just
conformed to what the norm was what the
narrative was we'd probably be in a lot
of trouble right that's the pathway to
authoritarianism and uh dictatorships
Etc so
it it has been historically the the
masculine I won't say men but the
masculine standing in the space of
non-conformity I won't conform to that
narrative right or I won't conform to
who it is that you want me to be or who
it is that you're telling me to be or
what it is that you're telling me to
believe and in doing so we create a
space where it's like oh maybe there's a
possibility for me to see what it is
that I want right so if you're telling
me that I should work a nine to five job
and I should buy a house or the white
picking fence and get married at this
age and have 2.2 kids
and that's what I'm supposed to conform
to
does that actually make me happy right
does that actually interest me at all or
can I create space for me to venture out
into the world venture out into the
unknown and figure out what it is that I
actually want in my life the type of
relationship that I want the type of
person I want to be with and just figure
it out like the hard question is how do
you figure it out right well it's it is
by first admitting that you have no clue
right it's like Jung said that the first
step to the therapeutic process is
confession
and if you look in any therapeutic
modality any spiritual modality they'll
all say admission where confession is
the first step to just say actually I
don't know I don't know what it is that
I want or to admit I have been
sacrificing what I authentically want
yeah and giving that up in in order to
get something from you right and so when
we do that then the possibility opens up
of us being able to explore what it is
that we want or to own what it is that
we actually wanted to own what it is
that we actually are and I think that
that non-conformity is
appealing and attractive you know I
think that for a large uh for for a
large part we want people within our
culture and our society who are not
going against the grain just to go
against the grain right that's not
really non-conformity that's just
reactivity in the face of the the norm
or the narrative and that's what we see
a lot of in our culture right now you
know it's like there's the standard
narrative and then there's their
reaction to that narrative there's what
people want you to believe or buy or
agree to and then there's the reaction
to that the opposite is like I'm just
opposing this to oppose this and so
there's this there's this sort of binary
Loop that people are caught in right now
in our culture that doesn't leave a lot
of space for individuality so when you
can say actually I'm not going to
conform to either of those I'm not going
to get caught in this narrative but I'm
also not going to get caught in just
reacting and rebelling against that
narrative for the sake of rebelling
against that narrative you start to have
a sense of what it is that you actually
stand for and where you stand
it also for me I'm just this is my
experience because knowing what you want
and knowing what what resonates with you
part of the part of my tool is checking
in with the body so we come back around
to the body again because like even when
someone says a truth like my body gets
Goosebumps like it's not cold it just
happens it's like a it's like a yes or
you know something happens and then I
can feel a tightening and it's like oh
that's obviously not good
um so checking in with the body also
feels like a another way to bring that
into being a valuable tool
yeah and you know I think maybe I'll
just speak to this you know the reason
why I was asking that question before
what does it feel like to be around a
man who's disconnected from his body is
that that's often what a lot of women
are saying when they say I can't feel
you or I wish that you would be more
emotional or I wish you would tell me
more about how you're feeling or how
come you're not vulnerable with me how
come you don't share more or I feel like
I can't trust you but I don't know why
you know some version of that generally
speaking what's happening is the woman
is saying I can feel that you can't feel
yourself yeah you know I can I'm tuned
into the fact that you're unaware of
what's happening within your own body
and a man who's disconnected from what
he's experiencing below the neck is a
dangerous man
you know he just is you know there's a
man who's angry is not a problem a man
who's disconnected from understanding
that he's angry is dangerous that's
scary
right because if I'm unaware that I'm
actually angry and I'm acting from that
place unconsciously that's a problem
right and so we have to be willing to
again tune into the body as you're
saying and and be able to experience
like what am I actually what are the
sensations that I'm feeling you know
it's not just labeling the emotions that
might not actually so I feel sad oh I
feel angry okay my work's done you know
away we go it's like no no what are the
sensations that you're feeling and can
you ground yourself can you root
yourself so that you're not so caught in
your thoughts you know you're not so
caught in
what do I need to say and how do I need
to fix this and et cetera et cetera et
cetera and then in doing so you're
likely again acting in a very like
non-conformity way
or heard you say that uh
if if a man is to risk everything to be
a man like Risk Everything to be a man
what is like what does that mean for a
man to risk everything to be a man
what is risk and what is everything
so first off I've talked to a lot of men
you know I've worked with tens of
thousands of men over the last decade
from all over the world and what's
interesting is that a lot of men do feel
like there is a risk to
unapologetically saying I enjoy being a
man I am masculine you know that that's
actually going to elicit attack in
today's culture to just and I I've seen
that I've made posts just about I I love
being a man you know I don't I'm not I
don't apologize for being a man and how
reactive some people are to that notion
you should apologize men are dangerous
men have caused harm so
what it means to risk everything
for being a man being who you want to be
as a man is that you have to risk not
being liked you know you really do have
to risk that and you have to risk
knowing that
there are going to be aspects of your
life that are going to be largely
thankless from society you know it's
like 90 of plumbers in in the United
States are men you know 98 of the people
that get into our sewers and make sure
that that the [__] literally goes from
your house to the septic tanks and the
you know processing plants in America or
men you know a lot of these jobs that
are are being done by men are nobody
gives thanks for that no one's like
giving gratitude for that you know no
one's like thanking the electrician
deployment like you know we just built a
house and it was done entirely by men
thank you for the [__] not being all
over my house yes I'm down that too
but you know I so in a non-comable way
like we have to risk the fact that other
people might not like what we have to
say they might not like what we stand
for they might not approve of the life
that we want to live they they might
disrespect it they might attack it they
might think that it's
um
harmful or uh or something along those
lines and so we have to we have to risk
knowing in in a way that there are going
to be people that won't like the life
that you want to live you know and
do you know who Terence McKenna is you
ever heard it yeah okay he's got this
great saying that I love and I think
about all the time where he says you
know the world is entering into a space
where it needs an archaic revival you
know it's entering into this time where
we where we have created so many complex
problems that we have to reach back into
the very like depths of our human
evolution of what we created long and
long ago you know into the cabalian and
you know into Alchemy into some of these
old ways of looking at the world and you
know a lot of the work that I do is
bringing men through these old processes
of initiation that there's value in
initiation you know because you return
to the community to the society and
you're more capable and competent of
being of contribution to the things
around you in a meaningful way where you
get something from it but the risk is
that people might never know people
might never acknowledge you you know
people might might never agree with your
way of living or your way of being and
they might not ever value that and so
that's a risk in in a society that's
saying you know you should
you should live how you want to live so
long as it fits with what society's told
you it should look like yeah well the
risk in that is that you lose yourself
and you find no do you have no joy
you're confused you're miserable you're
in bad marriages or bad relationships
um I mean that that is an even bigger
risk I think the last thing that I would
say is that we
as human beings but I think specifically
as men we have to understand the risks
that we are
already taking on by staying in a place
of comfort
you know by staying in this
overly domesticated overly docile
unfulfilling way of existing where we
never get our ass out into nature
without our cell phone and spend five
days out in the wilderness to meet who
we are when no one else is around when
no social media is is giving you the
thumbs up that what you're doing is
great when you're not immersed in some
podcast or you know anything else like
that you're literally just in nature on
your own right to see who you are in
those environments and to rewild
yourself as a man and to get very clear
on what's the risk of living in this
overly apologetic overly domesticated
unfulfilling way you know and to really
get clear on that and to see the cost
that you're paying and likely the people
around you are paying for your
unhappiness because the truth is that
most men that are overly domesticated
are very unhappy you know they're very
unhappy they're not connected to their
Primal nature they're not connected to a
sense of wildness and and consequently
they're not connected to a sense of
aliveness in their life and so they're
searching for it in porn they're
searching for it in booze in partying in
drugs in hookers and whatever it is
right in gambling Etc and they're trying
to find this sense of being connected to
a deep wildness that they yearn for
internally but it's lost you know and so
that's the archaic revival within men is
to reach back and say not that we have
to go you know back to what things look
like traditionally 100 years ago that's
not what I'm advocating the store
systems back then were not that nice it
was just channels down the side of the
road so we haven't proved some things
thank you that's right that's right
that's right but like I'm not saying
that we need to go back to relationships
and how they looked or any of those
things I'm saying that we as men
can risk reconnecting to our own
wildness within and and to do that
around other men and there's there's a
potency in that you know and facing our
own Darkness within facing the trauma
that we may have experienced and the
abuse that we may have experienced and
the neglect that we may have experienced
might just be the first step on that
path and that our pain can serve a very
valuable purpose in our life right our
pain when we don't have purpose
right yeah we don't have purpose as men
or like I don't know what my purpose is
in life you know it's just like 300 000
books on purpose on Amazon right it's
like holy [__] man like how many
freaking books do we have to write about
purpose right right
when we as men don't have a sense of
purpose or direction or meaning in our
life where I have seen every man start
that creates a very valuable path is
with his pain is turning his pain into a
purpose and and prioritizing that
self-reflection and that healing uh will
always put him on a trajectory that is
far beyond what he could ever imagine
and I've seen it happen for so many men
that's where we need to begin but it's
also that there's a huge risk in that
you know as a man there's a huge risk a
huge reward as well I I'm a huge fan of
the masculine I I think that there is
such a place
in the future where there's balance for
the feminine as well as the masculine
when I say female and male and then the
feminine and masculine within each one
of us I mean this is next level reality
when we are all when we are able to
merge those two things within ourselves
to then be able to see that in someone
else and respect that I think that's I
just think that's when we evolved a
hundred a hundred percent I agree you
know I think that that's just such an
important aspect of our of our Evolution
right now and what I usually say to most
men is
we're we're very externalized as men
like we like to look out at the world
and solve that problem and like get
fully immersed in our external life and
so what ends up happening is that a lot
of men are trying to figure women out
you know they're trying to understand
the feminine by looking at women and
saying like what do you want and what do
you need and how do I make you happy and
if I can figure those things out then
maybe I can be happy internally or it's
a very rational process yeah and and so
what I say to most men is
stop trying to figure her out right stop
trying to figure her out or solve her
problems or you know any of those things
right she's not the journey women are
not the journey they're not the they're
not the path they're not the purpose and
that you are as a man your ethics your
morals your values who you are what your
purpose is what your function is in life
all of that is the adventure and so the
truth is that if you as a man want to in
in essence really understand the
feminine it's not going to happen by
understanding your partner or your
mother or your sister or the woman that
you work with
it's not going to happen by
understanding the feminine out in the
world it'll happen by understanding the
feminine within yourself
right so the moment that you can turn
towards your emotional body Your
Capacity to have compassion for yourself
as a man when you are abusing yourself
verbally right I mean the amount of men
that are that self-deprecate and talk to
themselves in a wildly abusive manner is
so it breaks my heart it breaks my heart
because I have worked with so many men
and I've heard their inner stories and
I've heard their inner narrative and
I've heard the way that they speak to
themselves oh my gosh like Michael
Singer and untethered Soul you'd never
be friends with that roommate like if
that roommate in your head you would
just never be friends with them no
totally you know and I I facilitate this
exercise all the time with men where at
a at a retreat or a weekend I'll have
them sit across with another man at the
weekend and I'll say okay write down
everything that your inner critic says
that your inner judge says and so
they'll you know they'll all be sitting
there and they'll be writing and they'll
say okay now
one of you is going to go first and
you're going to look at the other man
you're going to speak to that man
from your inner critic you're going to
tell him exactly what your inner critic
tells you and every single guy is like I
don't want to do that I don't want to
speak to him like that he's a good guy
it's like well then why the hell are you
speaking to yourself like that oh [__]
oh so they're they're looking at the
person and making judgments of whatever
whatever the critic says like you're
kind of short you kind of whatever right
and so
but that's a lack of compassion
internally it's a lack of nurturing
internally it's a lack of our capacity
as men to have a relationship with our
own feminine orientation and so you know
in my in in my book I talk extensively
about like here's what your relationship
to women teaches you about you as a man
it's not about figuring her out it's
about understanding who do I become when
I'm in relationship with her who do I
become do I become needy do I become
insecure do I become volatile and high
conflict do I become avoidant who do I
become because it's not about trying to
fix her or figure out it's about how do
I understand myself in a more depth
oriented way because that is so
rewarding every man wants to have a
certain level of emotional sovereignty a
certain level of self-leadership and
self-authorship and you know my work has
always been to guide men down that path
how can you learn learn more about you
how can you learn more effective tools
and resources to be more self-governed
to be more self-aware to be more
self-understood because it's from that
place that you're not only going to feel
more safe with women more attractive to
women more on your purpose more on your
mission but you are going to have such a
deep level of self-respect and that just
feels [__] good you know it just
feels good and I think that's what a lot
of men are craving and so we have to be
willing to look at the more feminine
oriented nature aspects and attributes
within ourselves and for a lot of guys
what that means is looking at their
relationship to their mother and they
that's where [__] gets very real [__]
gets real real I mean look like a quick
access point to anyone I made is I'm
like tell me about your parents right
yeah right yeah that's true though
because you know we I mean I don't know
is I don't know if this is true or not
but I tend to feel like
we attract one of our parents and we act
like the other that's what I experienced
anyway and I all and I totally thought
that the the one that I attract was the
problem but it's actually
a result of how I acted which is the
other one the one that you don't notice
and so I realized that I acted like my
mom by abandoning my feelings because
she didn't wasn't in touch with that and
didn't cultivate a relationship with
that so I did the same thing that she
did to me to my inner child myself and
then it put me in these situations where
I attracted relationships that weren't
in alignment
um so is that is that even accurate is
that how it goes or is that just my
experience no I mean that's pretty
common right like we
we gain a blueprint of foundational
blueprint of the feminine from how we
interact with our mother you know like
there's a from a developmental
standpoint like child child development
from a developmental standpoint between
the ages of zero and three there's no
difference no distinction for a child
between itself and its mother it
literally is its mother
so from a nervous system standpoint from
like zero to two from a nervous system
standpoint what a child is experiencing
is what its mother's experiencing right
it's so tethered I mean think about it
right it's literally literally was
plugged into Mom but Mom is feeling it's
feeling what mom's thinking experiencing
it's feeling and experiencing and so for
the first few years of its life as it
comes out of the womb I've seen this in
my son right my son is 20 months old and
what she experiences he experiences you
know and you can see it happening real
time and so we have to understand that
as men part of our work is to see
how do we view women what's our story of
the feminine how do we interact with
them based on how we were brought up
based on our relationship to our mom
based on the blueprint of you know this
entity this person that brought us into
the world and that can be very
challenging because for some men mom
wasn't around mom was critical mom give
them up for adoption you know
nothing was ever good enough from um mom
was emotionally volatile and you know
told the boy about how you know she
would never want him to be like his
father and that you know his father is
you know all this stuff and so so we can
have very tumultuous relationships with
that and we can keep women at Bay that
we love simply because we're acting out
this old story that women are unsafe or
women always shut me out or whatever it
is it bookends the conversation a little
here with the final final chapter of the
final section in your book being about
um the final boss is the victim yeah
which is you know I'd written something
very different than what's in the book
initially which was a much more like
social commentary
and my my editor was like this feels
like it's you know because the book is
very much designed for a man to go
through it and learn about himself but
also do a tremendous amount of work
there's exercises and questions
throughout the book because you know we
as men we react and respond to being
called to something but we also want to
do things in order for Change and
transformation to happen so I made it
very doing oriented but the the initial
uh part that I had within the victim was
very much a social commentary because
our current Society is in some ways
reorienting itself and restructuring
itself around victimhood and there's
this kind of hierarchy of suffering that
is being created within our culture and
that hierarching hierarchy of suffering
and victimhood is saying the more that I
perceive myself to be victimized the
more power I think that I should have
within culture and Society
and so victimhood has become a way to to
Garner power right to gain power over
other people right what you said is
offensive to me and that hurts and
that's violence and so that right that
means that you're wrong and I can do and
say whatever I want to you right so
anyway I didn't write about that what I
wrote about was how you want to hear
about identity politics what uh not
generally no let Jordan Peterson handle
that yeah but yeah Peterson's got that
for days you know him and Andrew take
can go out there and and uh you know I
mean there's there's value in in a
little bit of everything of what people
are talking about but yeah Peterson does
an interesting job of that I I like
listening to him sometimes
um but what I did talk about was how
for us as individuals the victim is the
hardest thing for us to see no one no
one no one no one that is a human being
wants to see where they're being a
victim you know no one wants to admit
where they have felt victimized and no
one wants to see where they are acting
like a victim even if they aren't a
victim and this is what happens a lot
within relationships is that you'll see
and hear the couple start to talk about
fairness it's like tally keeping well I
did this yesterday and I watched the kid
for this long and I took the garbage out
but I wash the dishes right and so you
don't appreciate that and what's
happening is that the two people are
sitting in the space of I'm the victim
here and you're the person that's
causing me pain right you don't
understand me you don't see me you're
not acknowledging me you're not giving
me validation you're not appreciating me
right and so
that erodes relationship victimhood
erodes relationship and the challenge is
is that it's our individual
responsibility to see where we are
playing the victim and where we
genuinely have been hurt and victimized
and to heal that you know at the
beginning of the book I talk about
um I'm a man who has been abused and I
am a man who has abused others or I am a
man who has been hurt and I am a man who
has hurt others it is very challenging
for us to admit when we were abused when
we were hurt and then to see how we pass
that pain on to see how we've passed
that hurt on right and so we have to be
willing to see where maybe we were put
in a victim position as a child you know
where we were verbally abused or
emotionally abused or neglected or
abandoned or sexually abused or whatever
the case may be right bullied at school
Etc we have to be willing to see that
because otherwise if we're if we ignore
that pain that pain will come out in our
life and it will put other people in the
position that we were in we will
literally become the Arbiter of the pain
that we experience and we will pass it
on to other people unknowingly because
pain unaddressed is pain that we pass on
yeah so that's part of our work as men
you know to feel Sovereign to feel
confident to feel confident to to be the
type of fathers and husbands and leaders
that we ultimately want to be is to come
into contact with the pain that we were
given it always comes back to pain
pretty much yeah thank you for all the
good work you do and all that you've
already shared in this book I'm sure
will be a hit and I love that it starts
with the shadow I mean I think this is
valuable for anybody but you know I look
forward to the day when men and women
like I described you know you you know
come together within themselves so that
we can come together uh in the world and
I just think we're you know it's the
next level existence where there's more
Harmony and more more more progress and
yeah that'll be a nice place to live
yeah more more honoring of the masculine
the feminine versus the the degradation
of it you know the creating of it the
masculine and The Feminine honoring both
yeah thank you thanks Danica thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the Subscribe button